Hey Guys！
I'm　はじめ
And...
ジェ　　　　ｳﾞｧｯ
今日の動画は トミックゲームが
新しくなりましたよっ!
いえい！（拍手）
いえーい！なんでだよっ！ｗ
はっははっはｗ
はっーっなんかでか…
はい、と言うわけで、トミックゲーム皆さんご存知でしょうか？
はじ）いつでしたっけ？　　トミ）２０１４年
２年前ですか？
２年前か！
我々は、赤子の時ですわぁ
はっはっはは
トミックゲーム、　２年前に　僕たち　がやって
当時、地味に流行ったんですよね？
覚えやすいゲームだったんで
皆さんが  いろいろ  楽しめた  らしいんですけども
ちょっとあれ、やっぱ古いと
あの、特殊攻撃が、古い、と。
今の我々の動画のスタイルとはもう特殊攻撃がリンクしてないので
ルールを一新することにしました
「そういう事だ」
よっ！
あの、何たっけ、ｱﾚと同じ。　人も進化すれば、ゲームも進化する。
２０１６年バージョンにゲームを少しだけ、改造しました。
改造した内容ってのが有りましてですね、
基本的ルールは同じで、ございます。
「テュ」はもう禁止
あれは、不快になる人が多いらしかったので
ホントに？
適当です
例えばトミックさんスタートの時は
楽しくなってきたね
実際にやってみましょう　じゃトミックさんからスタートしましょう
それではゲームをはじ・・めて。。いきたいとぉー
それではゲームを始めて行きたいと
思いまーす
と　み　か　ら　は　じ　ま　る　リ　ズ　ム　に　あ　わ　せ　て
は　じ　に
は　じ　は　じ
と　み　さ　ん
と　み　と　み　と　み
という感じでですね
基本的な遊び方は変わりません！
始まり方がちょっと変わるだけなので
これは注意してください
そして、ここからですね
特殊攻撃 全部新しくなります！
ええと 今まではですね
「今日のセカンドチューンは」とか
「チューン」って
ちょっとそれ…
それ君のでしょｗ
あ、「なんと、なんと…」ってやつ
「なんと、なんとですね！」も もう言わなくなりましたね
あれ言わねえな
あれなんか もう初期だぜ
原始人みたいな…
新しく、特殊攻撃を
より シンプル、かつ 楽しく
２つにしました
まさに、シンプル イズ ザ ベスト
ってことだね
あぁ？
え？
ウウゥゥゥ
１つ目
全員を攻撃できる特殊攻撃があります
その名も…
これ、僕が考えました
こちら！
「パックマン」
リピート・アフターミー
No no no no...
「パ ッ ク マ ン」
「プァックマン」
NO no no no...
リピート・アフターミー
「ピクミン」
まあ、こういうなんかトミックさんとあるんで
これを特殊攻撃にします
この○○の中は、ええと…
好きな英語を入れてください
例えば、「アップル」とか「バナナ」とか
で その、「リピート・アフターミー・バナナ」
と言ったら
他のそのゲームをプレイしている人全員で
「バナナ」です
「「 バナナ 」」
…という感じ
全員で「バナナ」ってやります
「リピート・アフターミー」をした後は
その技を言った人が続けてまた
攻撃することができます
で、もう１つ
これはトミックさんが考えた技です
こちら！
…と。思いま～～～～～～～…
長い！
例えば、はじめくんだったら…
「はじはじ さばいていきたいと。思いま～す」って言ったら
２回叩いて、その人に「トン・トン」
その人の方向に向かって「トン・トン」
本人は、本人を「トン・トン」
こんな感じ。
「トン・トン」
じゃあ僕がトミックさんを攻撃するときは
こんな感じです
せーの…
とみとみ  さばいていきたいと 思いま～す
「トン・トン」
いっでぇ！
…という感じでございます
この特殊攻撃をしたときは
特殊攻撃された人が
次攻撃する番になります
これを踏まえて軽くちょっとやってみましょう
それではゲームを始めていきたいと…
思いまーす
は　じ　か　ら　は　じ　ま　る　リ　ズ　ム　に　あ　わ　せ　て
リピート・アフターミー・( ﾋﾟｰ )
( ﾋﾟｰ )
と　み　に
と　み　と　み
は　じ　よ　ん
は　じ　は　じ　は　じ　は　じ
リピート・アフターミー・( ﾋﾟｰ )
( ﾋﾟｰ )
と　み　よ　ん
と　み　と　み　と　み　と　み
今日の…
あぁーーー！
それではゲームを始めていきたいと…
思いまーす
と　み　か　ら　は　じ　ま　る　リ　ズ　ム　に　あ　わ　せ　て
は　じ　よ　ん
は　じ　は　じ　は　じ　は　じ
とみとみ さばいていきたいと 思いまーす
トン　トン
は　じ　は…じ……ｗ
あの、「とみとみ」と「トントン」が
ごっちゃになるんすよ
そう、とみトントンだよ、とみトントン
それは違う。
そうか。
はい。
という感じでですね、ちょっと難しいです
「トントン」もね、急にぶち込まれると難しいし
最後全部合わせてちょっと、ゆっくりやってみましょう
それではゲームを始めていきたいと…
思いまーす
は　じ　か　ら　は　じ　ま　る　リ　ズ　ム　に　あ　わ　せ　て
リピート・アフターミー・ライト
ライト
とみとみ  さばいていきたいと 思いまーす
トン　トン
は　じ　い　ち
は　じ
リピート・アフターミー・( ﾋﾟｰ )
( ﾋﾟｰ )
は　じ　よ　ん
は　じ　は　じ　は　じ　は　じ
リピート・アフターミー
バ…
バ？
バナナ
はっはっははｗ
リピート・アフターミー・バナナ
バナナ
リピート・アフターミー・トメィトゥ
トメィトゥ
リピート・アフターミー・シーラカンス
シーラカンス